Hey there, so happy to see you,
thank you for having me here.
I have to show these pictures,
I was lucky enough to do a movie with Andie,
back in the day, called Bad Girls.
There we are, 27 years ago.
Aw, that's a sweet picture,
I'll have to get a copy of that one, don't have that one.
Andie, you were so kind to me, I felt so.
How could I not be, you're just a sweetheart.
And I was saying, I don't know if you remember this.
Do you remember that time
when we were taking off on the horses?
That first time, you had that palomino horse right?
Bon Jovi, his name was.
Yeah, and anyway.
(laughing)
you just went ya, ya, like that
and just go flying past me, it was hysterical.
I was like holding on, you know,
to make sure, like well she's gone, there goes Drew.
Oh my God.
I just gravitated towards you so much.
I just hooked into you and I just would stare at you
and I was always happy to be with you,
and I would just stay really close to you
and I felt so cozy and happy,
every time I'd be with you all day long.
For months, we made that movie.
(laughing)
Brackettville, Texas.
Yes and right outside of Del Rio
and being at the border and the butterfly migration,
what special times, really.
Yeah.
Well I never did a movie with you,
but I mean I just adore you.
I loved all those movies and this new movie Now Mans Land,
Drew you just watched it, right?
I watched it last night Andy.
Good for you, yeah, these kids did a great job.
That's Jake Allyn and his brother Conor Allyn,
directed it and you know they did a beautiful job.
Actually they wrote the script as well
and they shot it with one camera,
so it's old school and really beautifully done.
I'm really happy for them, they're good kids.
It's very IFC, it's very beautiful
and moody and just a very stunning film.
I really loved it so I'm so excited
to be talking to you about it.
However, there is a film that you made, Groundhogs Day,
which now everybody since 2020 and the pandemic hits,
probably references every day
and tomorrow happens to be the Groundhog day all over again.
And I heard you say somewhere that the film
was about the pause in life,
so you can figure out how to get it right
and when you do, like that's when life resumes.
And I had never looked at Groundhogs Day that way
and I thought that that was the most enlightened,
beautiful take on our humanity
and the film Andie, I loved hearing you say that.
It really is about you know, having the opportunity
in life to become a better person.
And maybe this year, wouldn't that be great?
The whole world just become a better place.
Yeah.
And it is a lot like this year,
I mean we did pause, we'll see what we're gonna
be doing with that pause.
I Know like here, like the oceans here,
I'm in Canada and the whales are out, you know.
The whales are so relieved not to have
all those cruise ships out there, they have their space.
Yeah, the earth is happy,
the earth is taking a deep breath.
I think you're right, I think our going back to normal
should be a new approach, a thoughtful approach
and maybe we're gonna get it more right
and then life will resume
with a more thoughtful and careful approach.
(upbeat music)